es könnte sehr gut sein dass wir in
diesem video bock auf burger und pommes
bekommt und ich hab was für euch
anlässlich einer million abonnenten
eröffne ich ein kostenloses
burger-restaurant für fünf stunden
diesen sonntag brüsseler straße 43 im
herzen von köln seit dort ich freue mich
auf euch und jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video gp performance steht für schnelle
autos und gute bürger das ist wirklich
wahr und ich habe mir gedacht wie gut
sind diese bürger wirklich dein weg
boost bürger die performance ist
bürgerladen existiert schon seit über
vier jahren und ich war noch nie dort
das musste sich ändern deshalb sind wir
hingefahren aber nicht allein sondern
wir haben das gesamte büro mitgenommen
das sind leo dave erik und ich aber auch
der bürger gut war seht ihr jetzt
geschafft einhalb stunden fahrt krank
ist viel größer als gedacht hab da alles
von dir das alles ist grau android
fahrzeug folierung nicht so wo ist jetzt
putzt burger sind damit drin soll ich
nicht aufgehoben
hier darf man nun perfekt ein park in
einem zug seite gegeben ich muss halt da
guck mal da siehst du schon die ganzen
die ganzen san francisco die
akkubetriebenen megabyte reiser vacation
alter golf gti sagt wir brauchen jetzt
ein bus sofort her damit gp das ding ist
ich weiß wirklich nichts über booz
bürger außer dass es existiert das heißt
es wird sehr sehr interessant der
fußball direkt
unter dem büros komplett meter effekte
wie man sich für auch mit der musik hier
wie bei der post
new york sid original alles so auf und
da vorne ist ja nachdem schon einfach
mittendrin ist geil fett zum zweiten
platz und fehlen das ist so gewachsen
und natürlich natürlich gewachsen also
ja genau cartel checken hamburger und
ausstattung also also so auto inspired
stage 11 ist so leistungssteigerung ist
aber nach hamburger ecco geld das sagt
dass das dazu verdammt dass deutsche
bürger für bürger oder überall gemacht
an der decke habe nicht gestimmt zaubern
aber seht ihr diese motorhauben hier
oben so dass es schon geil geil
thematisch stilisiertes ich glaube schon
verdammt geil special bürger mit fünf
schulen
verdammt klein special burger und
zündspulen dazu saucen catcher meiler
sind und selbst bei dieser auf der dann
wäre es schon noch einen verdammt geil
special burger dazu müssen die bürger
wohl gerne nochmal diese these krakauer
currywurst
[Musik]
weil sie schon sehr sehr gut ausgesehen
sehr sehr muss ich auch sagen motto freu
mich auch um normal laufen sagt ja das
beste gewürzt und ich bin sehr sehr gut
gewürzt auf jeden fall weiß auch um
normal denn die anrichte ja so normal
bürger wird ja so
aber dieses offene nach oben mit allen
die uns ausdrucken das ist auch so
dieses das kann ja auch nicht her 99 den
darm oder industriegebieten aber
vollkommen in ordnung für mich kein
vollkommen in ordnung haben ihr gesicht
des trommelns beziehungsweise die wie
heißen noch gleich diese schulen sind
das zehn kerzen sind
der bürger habe kann als turbolader der
bekommt im krankenbett auch schon eine
gegessen das ist ein echtes angebot
gemacht alles tablett diese auflage gibt
ja bei einfachen und alles ist hier von
a bis z durch friend also es ist wie ein
remake ist eigentlich so becher dazu
nicht zu vergessen die auch durch dieses
sehr hochwertige hartplatz der kampf das
böse will und dadurch dass die leute
hier kommt das halt fügen bringen sind
entweder wieder mit oder haben meistens
andenken für zu hause das macht es
nachhaltiger als die normalen pappbecher
oder sowas teppich hat mich anfangs habe
ich ja schon gekommen sind also
überdurchschnittlich
gibt ein bisschen die schmecken als
super krass macht steht das ändern also
wir haben so super sind getränke sehr
lecker nicht ganz so gut wie die von
händler und gordon ramsay das war
wirklich krank waren krankheit aber ich
bin mir relativ sicher ist mir relativ
sicher
dass der bürger besser
red bull racing
was willst du erstmal ganz wichtig dass
kartoffeln pommes majo
echt vom transfer von franchise sind die
normalen pommes aber wie so oft
selten so uns stimmt aber die sind super
lecker also die normalen pommes und safe
besser als bei allen gängigen
besser dieser kann ich meinen kurzen
prozess auch am barren die bands sind
nicht so klassische prior spannend würde
ich sagen aber es ist super projekt
kennen so band von dingen nur von
cheeseburger in berlin aber ich kann mir
jetzt hier so ein richtiges
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schwimmbecken des plans salat frisch das
verbindet sich alles sehr sehr schön
punkt
das ist ein großer bürger gramm petit
ist wirklich saftig gebratenen also
nicht so super durch oder so schmeckt
man aufpasst
man sieht wirklich wie saftig dieser
baron und so
das sagt wird oben das ist gebrandet
mitbürger nein nur bei meinem nicht nur
ich hab kein branding bekommen ich
glaube es ist halt nicht ganz durch
gekommen aber für gewöhnlich sind die
bands glaube ich mit wick muss gebremst
was müssen bb angebissene spam also ich
muss wirklich sagen liebe zum detail
aber das haben wir auch so auto leute an
sich um liebe zum detail in ihren autos
und so hat auch hier wirklich ins bein
das muss man ja auch sagen da stehen ja
super kolleg anderen und das sind alles
autos aus den projekten von jackie also
man kann quasi nachdem man die videos
alle geschockt hierher kommen die autos
sehen und gar nicht so bürgerfraktion
übrigens über 11.000 google bewertungen
haben also wirklich komplett wahnsinnig
und es gibt richtige krieger von
wirklich fördern auch ich bin eigentlich
nur aufmerksam geworden weil mir
abonnenten stimme hatte ellenlange
nachricht max muss das essen das der
gast über und ich muss wirklich sagen
ich führe jetzt ein sehr sehr guter
bürger vor allem weil ich das gefühl
habe auch so die zwiebeln und so ist
alles richtig frisch auch hier die
einzelnen sagen war ein schöner höherer
nicht so zusammen gemacht wie five guys
ja bessere quali frischer geiles
branding geiles gefühl hier im laden
also aber wie das karamellisiert ist
dass das petit das ist wirklich
[Musik]
lecker under so wird die probieren gar
nicht so verrückt zu machen das ist
einfach super gut aber ich muss wirklich
sagen wir sind jetzt den ganzen weg aus
köln gekommen diese kombination war die
soße findest du auch gar nicht in köln
also das ist irgendwie so ein hybrid das
hat so sorgte bands und das die größe
das format von einem klassischen burger
mbtn großen partie aber es hat trotzdem
aus elementen smash bürger dann aber
wieder viel gemüse und sehr lecker was
man die definitiv sagen haben ist dass
es nicht funktioniert weil es ein genie
ist sondern lisa laden könnte in köln
stehen und der bankensektor ab ob also
es wirklich einfach ein richtig solides
gutes produkt
vorne zu dritt geschäft bürgerfest und
für hälfte kommt ein auto gestellt sich
schon ein ordentliches
sättigungsbeilagen verdampft ein spezial
burger danach ist aber autofahren nicht
mehr zu empfehlen der ist so ein
arschloch dass du einfach danach musste
ich möchte noch so jung ist so als wäre
ich natürlich dass ich mich schnell zwei
burgers aber gehen sie nach dem
billigsten und das ist die form ist da
ich noch habe 30 folgt dann war ich kann
es schon fast nicht mehr essen ist ernst
und legt dann alle von uns sind richtig
satt jetzt muss mir aber natürlich noch
nicht wikinger rallye bei
müssen wir noch beißen aber ja die
helligkeit so genannte schönsten man
merkt schon am gewicht dass es jetzt
nochmal ordentlich kalorien beweis für
die gleich autopilot
da muss ich hin
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja so kleber für den monat mai und noch
mal schokolade superflache
die sind tot er ist noch kein so aus
alter sozusagen wie üblich ich probiert
erst mal zwei stunden nicht
einzuschlafen und dann sage ich meine
gedanken zu diesem essen noch bei aber
kann jetzt schon sagen
es ist jetzt einen tag später und ich
bin immer noch sagt so fühlt sich
zumindest an also wenn man eine sache
wird von diesen bürgern dann satt aber
wie das detaillierte feedback lautet cds
wie viele andere auch habe ich einen
weiten weg auf sich genommen um big
buchberger zu testen etwas über vier
jahre nach der eröffnung wirken konzept
und restaurant design technisch modern
und durchdacht das personal hat
freundlich und geduldig unsere
bestellung aufgenommen zum essen die
pommes waren sehr knusprig die
süßkartoffel pommes lecker das highlight
waren die burger software bands außen
knusprig und innen saftige pettys und
ausgefallene saucen die bürger sind
schwer mit denen anderer ketten zu
vergleichen und das ist auch gut so
lohnt sich die anreise und der besuch
ist ein echtes erlebnis 55 punkten also
dann leute das war's von meinem video
ich muss wirklich sagen war sehr positiv
überrascht grüße gehen raus und jackie
wir haben sogar noch mal kurz gesehen am
ende hat er selbst für seinen videofilm
vielleicht sind wir sogar zu sehen und
wir sind vom nächsten video wieder macht
gut bis dahin und ciao